taking a look at the vaccinations
happening in our state you can see
things
are still on a down slope it's actually
been that way since mid-april
even after the governor announced cash
incentives for those
getting the shot thanks for joining us
here at 11 o'clock i'm denise feldas and
i'm brian loftis so the big question now
what more can the community do to
encourage those who have not been
vaccinated yet to get their shot
oracle mana spoke to those behind local
pop-up clinics tonight to found out to
find out more orco
well denise and brian according to the
state's covid dashboard
only about 45 percent of all eligible
nevadans
are fully vaccinated pop-up clinic
organizers tell us
that they're trying to hammer it home
that the vaccine is safe
and effective it's just ensuring that
we're meeting the community where they
are at this la bonita supermarket in the
northwest valley the site of a pop-up
vaccine clinic wednesday night hosted by
me familia vota
efforts are ramping up with less than
half of all eligible nevadans fully
vaccinated mi me familiavota tells me
one reason for plateauing vaccinations
and the point of this event
is limited access to minority
communities but how do they convince
those who now can get a shot but still
won't
if they're like no like i have questions
once again we have medical professionals
here in which they can answer that
question and then
you know which drives them to get more
like the vaccine we're encouraging
people to get out to get vaccinated
we asked congressman stephen horsford
about vax nevada days which will
randomly give vaccinated nevadans a
total of 5
million dollars in prizes i'm for
anything that helps people
understand the importance but what about
those who still won't budge
i think the most effective way is by
family member to friend to church member
even first friday is working with the
fire department to host its second
vaccine pop-up for their july event
it's important to remind people of what
we're coming through right now
and what we're coming out of as we
gather back together to be as safe as we
can possibly be
everyone's goal we need to ensure that
the curve is going down
vast nevada days kicks off july 8 and
runs through august 26
and winners will be announced each week
and only those
who have gotten vaccinated are eligible
reporting live tonight orcomanna 8 news
now